ya hemos visto en vídeos anteriores como
las curvas de posibilidades de
producción y las tablas de producción
nos ayudan a calcular los costos de
oportunidad de producir algo en un país
y luego utilizamos esa información para
hablar de la ventaja comparativa en este
vídeo vamos a hacer algo muy similar
pero en vez de empezar con la producción
vamos a empezar con los insumos esta
tabla nos muestra las horas de trabajo
por producto y por país una tabla de
producción nos indicaría cuántos
carritos de juguete produce un
trabajador por día en un país
determinado pero una tabla de insumos
nos indica cuántas horas por día
necesita un trabajador para producir un
carrito de juguete en el país
son dos horas y esas dos horas de
trabajo son el insumo entonces en esta
tabla no vamos a contabilizar el número
de carritos producidos por día sino la
cantidad de horas que es necesario
invertir para producir un carrito de
manera similar se nos muestra el insumo
que se necesita en el país
y para producir un cinturón una hora de
trabajo en el país se necesitan 4 horas
de trabajo para producir un carrito de
juguete y tres horas para producir un
cinturón lo siguiente que vamos a hacer
será convertir esta tabla de insumos en
una tabla de producción con la que
seguramente estás más familiarizado para
hacerlo simplemente suponemos que en
cada país se trabajan ocho horas por día
a partir de ese dato podemos elaborar
una tabla de producción en la que vamos
a colocar la producción de carritos y
cinturones de los países
y ver cuántas unidades de cada producto
puede producir por un día un trabajador
en cada uno de estos países vamos a
poner los carritos de juguete en esta
hilera y los cinturones en esta otra
entonces cuántos carritos de juguete y
cuántos cinturones por trabajador y por
día pueden producir los países a ive
si logramos llenar la tabla de
producción a partir de los datos de la
tabla de insumos podremos calcular el
costo de
oportunidad de una manera tradicional y
luego averiguar qué país tiene la
ventaja comparativa sobre cada producto
empecemos con los carritos de juguete en
el país y si en este país se necesitan
dos horas para producir un carrito de
juguete y si un trabajador trabaja ocho
horas al día entonces puede producir
cuatro carritos cuatro carritos por dos
horas son ocho horas entonces en el país
a un trabajador promedio puede producir
cuatro carritos de juguete en un día
simplemente tomamos ocho horas y las
dividimos entre el número de horas que
se necesitan para producir un carrito de
manera similar si un trabajador trabaja
ocho horas al día y necesita una hora
para fabricar un cinturón entonces el
país
puede producir ocho cinturones por día
podemos hacer lo mismo con el país ve
pausa el vídeo y si aún no lo has hecho
trata de llenar su columna en el país ve
cada trabajador necesita cuatro horas
para producir un carrito de juguete
esto significa que tenemos que dividir 8
entre 4 para obtener que en el país ve
un trabajador puede producir dos
carritos de juguete por día de igual
manera si se necesitan tres horas para
producir un cinturón dividimos ocho
entre tres y obtenemos que en el país ve
un trabajador puede producir ocho
tercios de cinturón por día esto es
igual a dos y dos tercios de cinturón
por trabajador por día como puedes ver
una tabla de insumos puede convertirse
fácilmente en una tabla de producción
ahora usemos estos datos para calcular
el costo de oportunidad vamos a hacer
otra tabla para el costo de oportunidad
de los carritos de juguete y los
cinturones en los países a ive en
cualquier momento puedes pausar el vídeo
para ver si puedes calcular el costo de
oportunidad con la información que
tenemos ya utilizamos la tabla de
insumos para obtener la tabla de
producción y ahora vamos a utilizar la
tabla de producción para obtener el
costo de oportunidad entonces cuáles
costo de oportunidad de los carritos de
juguete en el país a una manera de
plantearlo es pensar en que el país
se necesita la misma energía para
producir cuatro carritos y ocho
cinturones vamos a usar la letra c para
referirnos a los carritos y la letra be
para referirnos a los cinturones
entonces si dividimos ambos lados entre
cuatro la energía necesaria para
producir un carrito es igual a la
energía que se necesita para producir
dos cinturones entonces el costo de
oportunidad de un carrito es de dos
cinturones y si tomamos esta ecuación y
dividimos a ambos lados entre ocho
obtendremos el costo de oportunidad de
los cinturones 4 entre 8 es la mitad de
la energía necesaria para producir un
carrito y es igual a la energía
necesaria para producir un cinturón
entonces el costo de oportunidad de un
cinturón es la mitad de un carrito
observe que el costo de los carritos es
el recíproco del costo de los cinturones
a hacer el mismo cálculo para el país ve
pero antes quiero enfatizar en que
pongas pausa al vídeo y trates de
resolver esto por ti mismo en lugar de
sólo ver cómo lo hago así se te grabará
mejor en la memoria bien en el país ve
con la misma energía que se necesita
para producir dos carritos se producen
ocho tercios de cinturones dividimos
ambos lados entre dos y obtenemos que la
energía necesaria para producir un
carrito es igual a la energía necesaria
para producir cuatro tercios de cinturón
que es lo mismo que uno y un tercio de
cinturón y si tomamos esta ecuación y
multiplicamos ambos lados por tres
octavos
tenemos que tres octavos por 12 es igual
a 83 debe por tres octavos estos se
anulan y aquí vamos a tener seis octavos
de cee que es lo mismo que tres cuartos
de cee y esto es igual a b entonces con
la misma energía que se necesita para
producir un cinturón podemos producir
tres cuartos de un carrito de jugo
así que una vez que conocemos todos
estos datos que acabamos de obtener qué
país tiene la ventaja comparativa en
carritos de juguete para averiguarlo
simplemente comparamos los costos de
oportunidad de los carritos de juguete
en ambos países en el país y el costo de
oportunidad es de 2 cinturones mientras
que en el país es solo uno y un tercio
de cinturón entonces el país ve tiene la
ventaja comparativa en carritos de
juguete para los cinturones la mitad de
un carrito es menos que tres cuartos de
un carrito así que el país
tiene la ventaja comparativa en
cinturones es interesante observar que
el país ve tiene la ventaja comparativa
en carritos de juguete porque tiene un
costo de oportunidad más bajo a pesar de
que el país tiene la ventaja absoluta
porque sus trabajadores son más
eficientes en la producción de ese
producto un trabajador puede producir
cuatro carritos en el país
mientras que en el país sólo produce dos
pero
de eso en realidad lo que tiene sentido
debido al costo de oportunidad más bajo
es que el país vez se concentra en
producir carritos de juguete y que el
país se concentre en producir cinturones
lo más importante que hay que entender
es que en este ejemplo para determinar
la ventaja comparativa no abordamos la
producción desde el principio empezamos
con los insumos los convertimos en
producción luego calculamos el costo de
oportunidad y finalmente pudimos
determinar qué país tenía la ventaja
comparativa en cada producto hasta el
próximo vídeo